Are you excited yet? We hope you are. We
think you should be. Just look at all of these
pictures of Google data centers. All the Google services run
on the infrastructure that you see. And with the Google
cloud platform and app engine, this infrastructure is also available
to you. That means that the code you create in
this course will execute alongside all of the other Google
services. And can leverage from the same scale security and
performance that Google has built out over the years. We
can't wait to get started and have you on your way
to write and deploy your own code into these data centers
on your journey to writing scalable applications in the Google Cloud.